karfreitag ohne pilgermassen in
jerusalem erinnern nur einheimische
christen an den tod jesu touristen sind
nicht zugelassen
dramatische lage in polen mit
hubschraubern müssen corona patienten zu
den letzten freien krankenhäusern
gebracht werden und ostern in alten und
pflegeheimen bei dort viel geimpft wurde
dürfen wieder mehr besucher zu ihren
angehörigen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara legten abend und ein herzliches
willkommen an meiner seite ist für den
sport norbert lehmann ein stück von mir
stiller freitag so wird der karfreitag
auch genannt in diesem jahr scheint er
erneut besonders still
zum zweiten mal in folge können viele
diesen feiertag nicht so begehen wie sie
das gerne möchten auch in jerusalem
früher kamen jedes jahr zehntausende
pilger um den leidensweg christi ganz
nah zu sein letztes jahr dann
ausgangssperre
nur ein paar mönche durften die via
dolorosa entlang ziehen
diesmal konnten zumindest einheimische
christen den karfreitag wieder mit einer
prozession beginnt michael beverunger
aus jerusalem
so voll war es in der engen via dolorosa
schon lange nicht mehr um die 2.000
menschen folgen dem kreuzweg jesu auf
der traditionellen karfreitagsprozession
in jerusalem
es sind vor allem einheimische arabische
christen das vergangene corona jahr hat
viele ausgezehrt die besinnung auf leid
und tod geht dieses jahr besonders nah
am schmerz jesu teilzunehmen das
bedeutet mir heute sehr viel
besonders in dieser zeit in der wir alle
unseren eigenen schmerz zu tragen haben
in dieser globalen pandemie die so viele
leben genommen hat was fehlt sind die
pilger aus aller welt noch sind die
grenzen dicht nur wer länger lebt oder
wie diese jungen frauen ein soziales
jahr absolviert kann bei dem einmaligen
erlebnis dabei sein
[Musik]
gerade haben weil es ist schon nicht so
voll und es ist schon was besonderes
dass sich israels grenzen für pilger und
touristen wieder öffnen wird allerdings
noch dauern
fast eine normale karfreitagsprozession
doch bis auch wieder pilger ins land
dürfen muss sich die korona situation
erst weltweit entspannen
dennoch freuen sich die vertreter der
christlichen konfessionen in der stadt
über die rege teilnahme
ganze vier leute waren wir im letzten
jahr auf der via dolorosa
heute sehen sie dass es zwar keine
bilder gibt dafür haben fast alle
einheimischen christen teilgenommen
traditionell endet die prozession in der
grabeskirche
dort wo der grabstein verehrt wird der
sich in der osternacht für jesus
geöffnet haben soll
bisher sei kaum darüber gesprochen
worden was das virus mit der seele macht
sagt heinrich bedford strohm der
ratsvorsitzende der evangelischen kirche
in seiner karfreitagspredigt viele
fühlten sich erschöpft verwundet und
ohnmächtig bei den gottesdiensten heute
galt es flexibel zu sein und kreativ wie
fabian köhler zeigt der wohnzimmertisch
umgebaut zum altar der
karfreitagsgottesdienst live gestreamt
ins netz pastorin simone liegt gespräch
durch die webcam zu den gläubigen ein
tag der konzentration an den
gottesdienst und kirche haben sich
verändert in der gemeinde der hochschul
pastorin aus hannover online ist fast
normal wie fehlt die kirche schon weil
ich schon alleine sind raum genieße und
bei mir auch dieses ankommen und bereit
machen für den gottesdienst fehlt jetzt
liegt der akzent erstmal auf der technik
und die erste service steht die
internetverbindung und hört das auch
alles klappen und henke powerpoint über
150 virtuelle kirchgänger so viele
dürften in dieser zeit zum realen
gottesdienst hier gar nicht kommen
einige kilometer weiter südlich die
kleine kirche von beleidigen einchecken
zur andacht teilnahme nur mit namen und
adresse pastorin elke strikt begrüßt
ihre gemeinde draußen über ein japan
danny hat viel verändert
ich glaube dass es unserer kirche gut
tut dass wir einfach vor dieser
herausforderung stehen ganz neu
nachdenken müssen wie kommen wir zu den
menschen und was brauchen die menschen
von uns selten war ostern so wichtig wie
gerade jetzt wir sind alle verwundet
genervt verletzt und wir brauchen
hoffnung wir brauchen zuversicht und die
ostertage sollen uns diese zuversicht
gemeinschaft erleben trotz abstand
openair predigt auf dem friedhof oder zu
hause im wohnzimmer
die bilder aus den gemeinden sind sehr
unterschiedlich aber nicht weniger
feierlich und online endet an diesem
feiertag ein gottesdienst mit winken
anstelle von gesang
nur wer über 60 ist soll ja in
deutschland noch den impfstoff von
astrazeneca bekommen doch was machen die
jüngeren die bereits einmal damit
geimpft wurden
die ständige impfkommission empfiehlt
jetzt für die zweite dosis auf einen
anderen hersteller umzuschwenken
hintergrund sind thrombose fälle vor
allem bei jüngeren frauen rund 30
solcher fälle meldet nun auch
großbritannien
der nutzen aber übersteige weiterhin das
risiko sagt die zuständige behörde
und so sehen die aktuellen coruna zahlen
in deutschland aus das rk ii meldet 21
1888 neue infektionen innerhalb von 24
stunden das sind 315 mehr als am
vergangenen freitag
es gab 232 weitere todesfälle
die sieben tage incidents liegt bei 134
viele fordern von der deutschen chor
ohne politik ein einheitliches vorgehen
und bessere absprachen der präsident des
bundesverfassungsgerichts dagegen
verteidigt das krisen-management alle
freiheitlichen gesellschaften hätten mit
kolossalen herausforderungen zu kämpfen
sagte stephan harbarth den zeitungen der
funke mediengruppe wenn man unter
zeitdruck und unsicherheit entscheiden
muss bestünde immer die gefahr von
fehlern
ein land in dem die korona lage immer
dramatischer wird ist polen nur knapp
halb so viele einwohner wie deutschland
aber alleine gestern etwa anderthalb
also viele neuansteckungen rund 35.000
neue fälle verzeichnet unser nachbarland
besonders betroffen ist die grenzregion
zu tschechien und die mediziner und das
pflegepersonal kämpfen nicht nur gegen
das virus sondern auch mit einem
gesundheitssystem das schon vor corona
oft überfordert war
aus warschau natalie steger die ersten
hubschrauber sind im einsatz verlegen
corvette notfälle in krankenhäuser in
denen noch ein platz zu finden ist
polens kliniken sind am anschlag
krankenwagen mit patienten in der
warteschlange
manche warten stundenlang auf dringend
benötigte medizinische versorgung der
engpass bei der effizienz des systems
ist der personalmangel
denn viele medizinische fachkräfte sind
in den letzten jahren in den westen
abgewandert
das polnische gesundheitssystem ist
schon in nicht coffee zeiten überlastet
jetzt erst recht
der verschärfte locker und zeigt wenig
erfolg vor allem wegen der schnelleren
britischen mutante explodieren die
zahlen deutlich mehr als in der ersten
welle
damals hatten wir täglich fünf bis 600
neue fälle und 10 bis 20 prozent davon
mussten ins krankenhaus
jetzt sind es weiterhin etwa 20 prozent
aber bei 30.000 fällen dazu kommt dass
die polen die anfangs mit viel disziplin
relativ gut durch die ersten beiden
wellen kamen gruner müde sind
polizeikontrollen nicht jeder nimmt es
mit masken pflicht und distanz regeln
noch so genau
das schlimmste aber so die regierung
stehe polen noch bevor denn bei so
vielen neuinfizierten dürfte auch die
zahl der intensivpatienten noch einmal
deutlich steigen
in brüssel hat die polizei eine große
illegale party aufgelöst dabei gab es
heftige ausschreitungen 26 beamte wurden
verletzt in einem park hatten sich trotz
corona krise mehr als 1500 menschen
versammelt um zu feiern
aus der menge wurden unter anderem
flaschen auf die polizisten geworfen
die sicherheitskräfte setzten tränengas
und wasserwerfer ein es gab mehrere
festnahmen
in den
atomstreit mit iran kommt bewegung die
usa waren vor knapp drei jahren aus dem
abkommen ausgestiegen des tehran vom bau
einer atombombe abhalten soll
heute haben die verbliebenen
vertragspartner darunter deutschland mit
iran beraten und anschließend betont
alle seien bereit das abkommen zu
erhalten und wieder mit den usa
zusammenzuarbeiten
schon anfang nächster woche soll es in
wien weiter gehen dann mit den usa ein
trauriger tag für die menschen in taiwan
bei einem schweren zugunglück im osten
des landes sind mindestens 51 menschen
ums leben gekommen und 100 45 wurden
verletzt
offenbar stürzte ein baustellen laster
vor einem tunnel auf den zug und brachte
ihn zum entgleisen
der expresszug prallte daraufhin und die
tunnelwand
für die helfer ist es schwierig zu den
betroffenen waggons vorzudringen
einige passagiere kletterten aufs dach
um ins freie zu gelangen
zurück nach deutschland
eines hat sich verbessert beim zweiten
ostern in der pandemie dadurch dass fast
alle über 80 jährigen in den alten und
pflegeheimen geimpft sind konnten die
besuchs beschränkungen in vielen heimen
gelockert werden
und so sind die feiertage zumindest für
einige nicht mehr ganz so einsam wenig
2020 aus sachsen berichtet anja charlie
peters ist froh dass sie ihre mutter im
altenpflegeheim naunhof wieder besuchen
darf unter strengen hygiene regeln
der schnelltest ist pflicht vergangenes
jahr waren an ostern nach corona
ausbrüchen in vielen heimen alle
kontakte untersagt das hat spuren
hinterlassen
in der zeit wo man sie nicht besuchen
durften da hatte sie doch ganz schön
abgebaut also allgemein die belohnung
für die 91-jährige reinmuth gerichte ist
das osterfest eilig die frühere
religionslehrerin hält die andacht am
ostersonntag
heute meiner ansicht nach ungeheuer
wichtig ein halt von den 50
pflegekräften im haus haben sich 30
impfen lassen
alle mitarbeiter werden dreimal die
woche getestet fast alle der 71 bewohner
sind geimpft nur in ausnahmefällen gibt
es ärztliche oder familiäre bedenken bin
dankbar dafür dass man sich dafür
entschieden hat die bewohnerinnen und
bewohnern von altenpflegeheim
zuallererst zu impfen
mit der mutter schon ihren wesentlich
größere sicherheit für die menschen die
mal zu dem wohlstand beigetragen haben
und dem wir uns heute auch freuen können
denn sie an ostern an uns dass geben uns
die bewohner hier mit auf den weg
sollten uns zu herzen nehmen und jetzt
herrscht im fußball und im basketball
da hat nämlich der fcb sportgeschichte
geschrieben der erste deutsche
basketballclub der die playoffs in der
euroleague erreicht hat nach dem zitter
sie gestern abend gegen kaunas der
münchner jubel überbordend nach
einzigartigen erfolg das team von
trainer andrea trinkt er bekam sekunden
vor schluss zwei freiwürfe zugesprochen
die wladimir lucic beide zur 71 zu 70
führung verwandelte den favoriten aus
kaunas blieben nur noch wenige
augenblicke doch wiederum lüttich mit
einer erfolgreichen abwehraktion der
entscheidende blog ein traum geht damit
für die bayern in erfüllung zum ersten
mal spielen sie die playoffs in der
euroleague der größte erfolg in der
deutschen vereins basketball geschichte
und zwei richtungsweisende topspiele
morgen in der fußball bundesliga
dortmund gegen frankfurt beide vereine
kämpfen die haben einen champions league
platz und der zweite leipzig gegen
tabellenführer münchen die bayern nach
sechs pflichtspielsiegen in folge 2 in
topform aber sie müssen ja auf ihren
verletzten torgaranten robert
lewandowski verzichten
wie sehr der 35 malige saisontorschütze
den bayern fehlen wird lässt sich in
beiden lagern nur vage ab
müssen wir mit trainer tiere müssen
schauen wie wir das am besten lösen weil
es im team natürlich weiterverteilern
aber wir haben wir haben spieler die auf
der position spielen können also von
daher natürlich ist ein spieler weniger
auf dem wir aufpassen müssen jetzt
müssen auf dem anderen aufpassen mit
zehn wenn sie nicht auftreten
sie werden besser mit ihm aber sind
trotzdem noch sehr gut das hinspiel in
münchen endete 3 3
aber das dürfte den verfolgern aus
sachsen diesmal nicht reichen wenn wir
nicht gewinnen oder unentschieden
spielen sehe es ähnlich
dann ist die saison nicht vorbei aber
der meisterkampf wahrscheinlich gewonnen
hat leiten sich gegen bayern erst einmal
den neuen bundesligaspielen kein so
gutes omen
das topspiel am morgen abend ausführlich
bei uns im aktuellen sportstudio ab 23
uhr
gut zu wissen fehlt noch das wetter im
norden scheint meist die sonne in der
mitte und im süden sind mehr wolken
unterwegs von oberbayern bis ins
südliche brandenburg kann es auch regen
oberhalb von etwa 700 metern
schneeschauer geben bei einem kalten
nordwind werden sechs bis 13 grad
erreicht und die ostertage bleiben kühl
am sonntag noch mit viel sonne am montag
regen und schnee nachrichten gibt es
hier wieder um viertel nach elf danke
für ihr interesse machen sie sich noch
einen schönen abend und bis morgen wenn
sie müssen auf wiedersehen